vers baptiste gpcg pêcher en balançant
des cafards dans la boue des jaunes dont
repris mon restaurant
il faut me comprendre mais baptiste et
il faut que dieu ne comprennent aussi
ceignac oui ces boules negro envahi la
france mais ils nous ont volé notre
travail
alors ma vie faut pas vous laisser
emporter par la haine et la colère
elles sont toujours mauvaises procédé je
parle pas pour vous berba tistes vous
mériteriez vraiment d'être blanc je
parle de [ __ ] qui vit avec ma fille
je vais pas renier qui ont appris mon
restaurant
c'est pour ça que pensent et s'est mis à
boire et c'est pour ça qu'il en est mort
si votre affaire a périclité
ce que l'on reprenne en sont pas
responsables au late il faut pas faire
de tous les étrangers les boucs
émissaires de votre malheur vous allez
me faire dit notre père est simple je
vous salue marie
mais il faut pas recommencer paulette
pas où commencer